today we're going to be coming CSPs but
possibly just as importantly you're all
halfway through the quarter so
congratulations
I think six more weeks to go so keep it
up
also happy Halloween hope you all have
fun but today we're going to talk about
CSPs
so this is continuing these topics that
we've been covering since Monday which
is about this kind of setting right so
you have variables in this case we have
3 X 1 X 2 and X 3 and each variable
represents some kind of discrete object
that can take on one of several values
and so the set of values that a single
variable can take on is called its
domain and just to continue reviewing
these variables have factors which are
functions that take as arguments one or
more variable and the factors basically
say ok how much do I like this
assignment of my variables so for
example a factor two looks at X 1 and X
2 and it says okay X 1 has been assigned
some value X 2 has been assigned some
value how much do I like that assignment
do I really like it if so you give it a
high value do I not like it if so you
zero it out and so importantly we call
the arguments so all the variables that
we give to a factor that's the scope of
that factor so we had this example that
we talked about on Monday and I'm just
gonna revisit it so in this case we have
variables correspond to people and
there's three people and we know that
first of all the first two people person
one person two they have to agree to
each other and then person two in person
three they sometimes agree with each
other but not all the time and so first
what we say is with our first factor we
say that person one is definitely blue
so we say this year by saying these are
the values that the variable can take on
red or blue and this is how much we like
that value and what this first factor is
saying is that it doesn't like read all
it's a zero and it likes blue it's a one
and then we have the second factor this
encodes the fact that they must agree
and with that saying is that every time
both the first variable which is X 1 and
the second variable which is X 2 and
every time they agree they're either
both red or both blue we give it a 1
otherwise we give it a 0 and then we
have this factor which says that they
tend to agree and we're encoding that by
saying well if they're if both of its
arguments are the same if they're both
red or they're both blue then we give it
a slightly higher number than if they
differ but we're not going to zero it
out and then last we say okay well the
last last person kind of prefers to go
red but you know it's not a hard
constraint nothing like that and so then
again so like we talked about last time
assignments which is like if you have
all your variables and you have all the
values that you've assigned to them they
have what's called a weight and a weight
is basically just plugging in all the
values for your variables into your
factors and then multiplying them all up
to get that product and that's the
weight and our goal across all of these
problems in this whole unit is to find
assignments for all of our variables
that will give us the maximum weight
when we multiply up all of our factors
yeah
yeah so the question was why is the
weight a product and not a son and the
answer for that is because remember
these are constraint satisfaction
problems and so if you look back at this
example we wanted to encode the
constraint that they must agree and we
did that by putting in a zero and since
we're multiplying it up if you have a
single factor that gives us zero it's
like a veto and so that veto power is
actually really critical and we
leveraged it on Monday which I'll talk
about soon so on Monday we talked about
an one algorithm for solving these kinds
of problems we called it backtracking
search and it's it's a kind of an
exhaustive you could think of as like a
depth-first search of all the
possibilities so we have this example
from last week where we were coloring
provinces in Australia right so we have
I actually don't know the problem since
of Australia but we have W a and we have
V and we have T I think T is Tanzania
Tasmania
I'll work on my geography but we color
them all red right and so what we decide
to do was beside to say will color cue
red let's do it and then we say hey if
we call her cue red let's go with green
here for n T and then we pick blue for
sa and then green for NSW and we've
completed that tree we've gone as far as
we can we found a coloring that works we
say oh wait what if we backtracked up to
this point and try to sub in blue in for
NT instead of green which is what we had
before and then we can do the same thing
we go down that branch of the tree or we
could try different colors for Q so for
example what if we try Q over here we
take that tree down oh but that gives us
something that is is not a size five
ball so for example here and si no
matter what color we give it according
to our factors which say like you can't
have two neighboring colors it would be
not allowed and you fill up the tree
this way and so this this is the
algorithm we covered and it works
because it always gives you a good
version but it's not working because
it's super slow it's exponential time so
there's n nodes and each node has a
and so your your it's like for each
value of here I can draw it out so like
for example if we had to fact if we had
two variables x1 and x2 and they both
took on three values so these are our
vet our variables and these are the
values they can take on and these are
how much our factors like them then you
would have to say for each value in x1
for each value in x2 so it's this
exponential blow-up which is just very
slow and so we learned some kind of like
heuristic ways to speed things up and
prune off that tree so we did forward
checking which is where like once you
decide my value for one variable I'm
going to go ahead and propagate that
decision as far as I can
that shrunk it a little bit we looked at
dynamic ordering which is like okay
which variable and I'm going to choose
to work next and then once I've chosen
that variable I'm gonna choose my value
a little more intelligently I'm gonna
pick the thing that has the least wiggle
room cuz maybe that'll help us uh one
second and that helped us a little bit
but at the end of the day these
constraints they helped us prune the
tree but they can only work for
constraints only if a factor gives us a
value of zero does it work because
that's when it has veto power and we use
the vetoes to say this branch of the
tree will never be useful so we can
never go down it so if we have factors
that are going to be nonzero we can't
use any of these things yeah we're on
the example how you got the number so
like 2 to the N minus 1 yeah so for this
I guess this example what it would look
like as a graph I guess it wasn't the
best example but and actually later in
lecture today we're gonna talk about
exactly how you could go about this more
smartly but let's say you just had two
variables leech had unary factors if you
were running binary like backtracking
search we would still say we would try
all different combinations
of both variables which is a very dumb
thing to do
yes so that's the backtracking search
interesting yeah so we'll discover a
smarter ways to get around that
yeah so that's backtracking slow but it
gives you the optimal solution every
time so maybe a mix back okay so I'm
gonna lead into this is a running
example that we're gonna be talking
about the whole lecture object tracking
so with object tracking you have sensors
that are selling you like oh my object
is here no it's down here oh wait it's
over here and what you want to do is you
want to take that noisy observation and
and run it through your CSP to infer a
more realistic estimate of where the
object actually is so I will also draw
this on the board so
so what this looks like is if we have
this is time so we'll call it t for time
and this is position so we'll call it P
for position and what this is going to
say is we have sensors that are giving
us estimates like noisy estimates for
where this thing is at every point in
time so for example maybe at time step 1
we get an observation down here at time
step 2 it's up here and at time step 3
it's up here but in reality like we want
maybe something more like that and so
that's gonna be our goal with this
running example so this is how we code
it into a factor graph in in this case
we have variables where the variable is
our guests for the real location for
that object we have two kinds of factors
we have unary observation factors that
say how close is our guests to the
observation to what our sensor said and
then we have transition factors which
basically tell us you can't change your
guests by too much from time step to
time steps so on this graph what it
would look like is if these are our
observations this is like o 1 o 2 and O
3 then maybe our first guess would be
here so we have X 1 down here we have X
2 down here and then maybe like X 3 up
here and so our observation factors is
going to look at this distance and that
would what this is going to say is okay
how far is our estimate from the
observation and they want that to be
close and then our transition factors
are going to look are you going to look
at this distance between one one guess
in the next guess and say well our
guesses shouldn't be moving too much
yeah
so the observation is what this sensor
gives us and the estimate is is us
saying thank you for the thank you
sensor now I think the person is
actually right here because the sensor
is noisy
we can't trust it yeah okay so that's
how we're gonna set up this problem and
I think so there's an and there's this
really cool kind of like Java applet
that you can all play around with on
your own time and I will briefly walk
you through it
so what's going on here is basically so
there's a lot of documentation that you
can read but basically tapping here is
we're just creating these variables we
have three variables and we're allowing
them to go in three positions so in
position zero one or two and then this
is a little function that's basically
encoding the fact that if things are
nearby then we want it then we like that
so we have two variables a and B and if
they're in the same position then we
return to we really like that if they're
only one away from each other we return
one so it's okay we'll take it and if
they're farther away then one from each
other then it's we zero it out that's a
hard constraint we don't like that and
then we have this observed function
which is kind of a higher-level thing
and it kind of um I guess you could say
it kind of like preloads our nearby
function with with a variable we're
going to create our factors and then
this is what it looks like so we have we
have three variables we have X 1 X 2 X 3
and then we have our observation factors
are unary remember that say okay you
have to be close to the sensor and then
our transitional factors are binary and
that says you can't move too much
between time steps and you can run it
and there's actually a lot of output
here and I'm gonna ignore most of this
for now I think the thing that is
important here is that we ran
backtracking search and we found the
optimal assignment so in this case it's
4x 1 2 4 X 2 & 3 4 X 3 which gives a
final weight of 8 so on our little
drawing basically what that's saying is
is it saying something like this is
optimal where we we put a we say thank
you sensor for these estimates but we
think the person is actually here at
time step 1 here at 2 and here at 3
that's the solution that backtracking
gave us yeah - so you know those are the
weights or the time steps as you're
saying it's like 1 than 2 so X 1 1 is a
time step 1 in the next 2 is the time
step 2 but X 3 is also time step 2 yeah
so the question was what do you mean by
here at 3 and what I mean is basically
so X I X I is an is our estimate for the
position of this object and so at time
step 3
our estimate for the position is at
position 2 and yep so X 2 and X 3 so
that's why there's X's at 2 for both
time visas like time step 1 2 & 3
yeah yeah ok I understand like what
you're talking about with the scope of
the factors but how exactly is there a
constraint being yeah so the constraint
here is so the fact that if we look at
our nearby function and if a and B are
farther than 1 away from each other then
it returns 0 and that's a constraint
because when we're calculating the
weight of a factor graph we multiplied
together all the factors and so if
there's a zero in there then the whole
weight goes to 0
yeah yeah you could say that yeah great
okay so that's our setup and we're gonna
be returning to that a few times awesome
okay so moving on on backtracking search
very slow let's try to speed it up beam
search faster yay
beam search so backtracking search if
you we have that tree analogy right and
backtracking search exhaustively
searches the entire tree gets us to that
solution but it's very slow and so one
way to avoid this kind of like
exhaustive search is greedy search which
is where you greedily it's like for each
variable you greedily select the value
that gives it the highest weight so it's
right here you look at the values you
can take on and you just choose whatever
variable whatever value is best and you
never look back you just keep on running
through it and you go through the whole
tree this way until you end up at a
complete solution so the benefits is
it's very fast right it's linear but the
con is that it's a very narrow window
like you don't see a lot of the state
space you don't explore a lot and so you
can often miss the global max so for
people who prefer this kind of notation
what we're doing is we basically say we
loop through all the variables and we
try out every value and we just take
whatever value has the highest weight
yeah so beam search is kind of like an
in-between backtracking and greedy beam
search is very cool so one way to think
yeah
yeah so the question was explained agree
again and so with greedy what we're
doing is as we say so we have we have a
partial assignment right and we pick we
want to extend our partial assignment so
we pick a new variable and we try out
every single value that that variable
can take on and then we take the value
that that that gives it the highest
weight so all the factors touching that
variable are the most happy with that
value and we pick that and then we never
look back and then we pick a new
variable yeah so the so that's a good
observation we can end up at
inconsistent solutions and that's
totally true so you can actually you can
enduring a greedy search you can
actually kind of like find your way in
kind of a hole where it's like oh damn
you know I can't go any further
and it's a big problem with greedy
search yeah so with backtracking beam
searches is kind of like a heuristic way
to maybe get around that
so with beam search so remember again in
in so for greedy search we had one
partial assignment right and we were
choosing one variable and choosing an
extension of that one variable with beam
search what you do is instead of one
partial assignment you maintain a list
of K partial assignments in this case K
is 4 and then what you do is on every
step is for each of your partial
assignments you pick a new variable you
try out all the ones and then what you
do is you so you have york a partial
assignments and you tried to extend
every partial assignment you test out
all the values for every partial
assignment and then you sort those
partial assignments based on their
weight and then you just take the top k
so it's like you have your partial
assignments you extend them into all the
possible successors you sort them based
on weight and then you take the top k so
in this case if we have four partials
assignments then we try extending them
all in the two directions they can go
and then we sorted them and then we took
the four you can see there's four things
that are filled in that have the highest
weight and we continue this procedure so
we say so what we would do in this case
is we would say okay for each of these
four solid things we're going to try out
we're going to extending each of those
partial assignments and then we sort all
the extensions and select the top K so
yeah yeah exactly so the question was up
to the part K right
and the quite and answer is yes yeah so
for example here for example one is less
in case we sent it to two still less
than K so we can extend completely so in
in notation yeah so we say for each for
each variable we we try to extend each
of our partial assignments and then we
prune out everything but the K largest
like best K waits so beep search is also
not guaranteed to find the best weight
but what's cool about it is that it
gives you kind of like a knob that you
can control between being greedy and
exploring a lot so if K is very wide
then you explore more more of the tree
and if K is actually infinity I think
this is on a slide soon yeah so if K is
infinity then that's actually like akin
to a breadth-first search of the entire
tree yeah on that graph or on the
picture we had like the solid in the
shade about once yeah for that shaded
out great ones we would actually never
explore those yeah so so this picture I
don't think it's the best picture
because so for example okay so I'm
looking like I'm looking right here and
in reality you would never extend this
because it was never selected
explore it and then find that it's not
yeah so up here so at this point we do
consider it because we extend down but
then we decided not to select it
yeah awesome run time so four okay so
four beam search you're selecting a
single node and then for for each
partial assignment you're trying out
every value in the domain so if B is the
size of your domains and then you're
trying out B things for every partial
assignment and you have K partial
assignments right so those are the
number of extensions you have is KB and
then to you sort them and to sort it
take if you have a list of length n
sorting it as n log N and so you sort
your list of KB so that becomes KB log K
B and then there's n nodes that you need
to the height this trees n so if you do
this n times so like I said beam search
of the K gives you this really cool knob
which mean do you want to explore
everything or do you want to focus in on
on you know being fast and greedy okay
so everything until now what we've
covered is is extending partial
assignments so we have we're giving like
a blank slate picture of Australia with
no colors and we say color me Australia
like build up this house from the
foundations and now what we're going to
talk about is okay given like a map of
Australia that's already filled with
covers colors how do we make changes to
it in order to improve it and that's
local search so the first algorithm is
called iterated conditional modes ICM
and what ICM is doing is it says okay we
pick one variable and then we ask how
what is a new setting that we could
choose for this variable that would
improve the overall weight so in this
case we have one variable it's x2 and we
try out all the different values that
can take on which is 0 1 or 2 and then
for each of those values we go through
and recompute the weight and then we
pick whatever value is best so we
started with 0 0 1 and here it looks
like one is a better choice so we go
with it and
and from this now on we would say X 2 is
equal to 1 so something cool about ICM
is that when you're evaluating a new
value for a variable
you only need to consider factors that
touch that variable that's all you
really need to recompute because
everything else is constant with respect
to it and so that gives you big big big
time savings in practice one last thing
is so the name iterated conditional made
so iterated comes to the fact that you
could solve the whole CSP this way if
you just iterate over which variable
you're selecting conditional means that
once you select a variable you're
clamping down the values of everything
else and then modes is saying once you
select your variable you you try out
every single value for that variable
yeah yeah so the question is if you kept
so if you have your three variables and
you keep on going through them and and
choosing one clamping the others and
then choosing the best value for it
would you wrap it in a flow solution and
the answer is no so and Wilson will see
that in practice yeah yeah so again this
that's this is just to give you in the
ocean that we iterate through these
variables and for each variable we pick
a weight that improves it so we have
this in the demo so in this case what's
going on here is we're saying okay right
now we've selected we're looking at x1
and we start with a random
initialization we start we're looking at
x1 and and these the different values
that x1 could take on and then we go
through and calculate the weight and we
say ok 1 is the best weight for x1 right
here so we choose one to be x1 and we
step again we're looking at x2 now and
oh it looks like actually a value of 1
is better for x2 and so from now on we
choose the value of 1 for X 2
and we iterate again now we're looking
at x3 and it looks like we choose the
value of one and you just keep on
iterating for this until you hit some
kind of local optimum and I'm saying
this is important that it's a local
optimum because right now it's converged
so I can keep on pressing step and it's
not going to change but the weight is
four and if you remember during the
other thing when we were in backtracking
we actually found an assignment with a
weight of eight so it does it can fall
into these local optimum one way around
this is a second algorithm called Gibbs
sampling with Gibbs sampling what we do
is we inject some randomness into the
process to try to like bump us out bump
us out of those local optimum into
something that can maybe get us into a
better area
so basically Gibbs sampling is super
similar to ICM the only difference is
that instead of so you you try out all
the values and instead of selecting the
value that gives you the biggest weight
you sample the value according with
probability that's proportional to its
weight so for this example we say
setting of zero would give us one value
of one would give us weight of two valve
two would give us a weight of 2 and then
to get the probabilities we take the
weight and we sum but we divide by the
total which would in this case would be
five we saw them all up and divide by
that that gives us a probably point two
so here we say it's 2 divided by 5 which
is 1 plus 2 plus 2 and then we use that
probability distribution to sample a new
value for X 2 instead of just choosing
it's like oh you're the best so this is
the demo so in this case we're looking
at X 1 and we're trying out different
probabilities for it and we have weights
and then that gives us a probability
distribution and we sample from this
probability nutrient so in this case it
looks like we sampled and we chose 0 for
X 1 and then we keep a record of how
many times we've ended up with a certain
assignment
so if we step again now we're looking at
x2 and it looks like x1 so a value of 1
is the only thing that works so we
choose that value and we add it to the
counts and you can just keep on running
this process and over time you build up
this kind of like probability
distribution so this is actually an
unlikely simple so I had a point it had
20 percent chance of choosing 1 and 80
percent chance of choosing 2 but it
still chose 1 and that's a way that it
can kind of like break out of these
local Optimum's but in any case if you
look at this table then what you find is
that over time if you run this thousands
millions of times then in practice
settings with very high weights will
occur very often and actually when we
get into problems like graphical models
which person we'll talk about soon you
could actually say that the global
optimum will be the most frequent and
good sampling in the limit which is I
think pretty cool yeah okay so just to
just to show an example of what can go
wrong with this algorithm it's still
flawed so if we have X 1 and we have X 2
and let's say let's say it's two people
and they're trying to decide where to go
to dinner so we could have let's say
they're deciding between vegetarian and
going to a steak house so we have V for
vegetarian and s for steak house and
they really both want to go to
vegetarian and they want to eat together
and they'll eat steak but they're not
super crazy about it
so if you're in this state then even if
you're doing Gibbs sampling it's really
hard to bounce over here because you
have these two kind of like
transitionary settings in between and in
order to make it to both vegetarian
they're going to have one is going to
to make the decision to go to a
different restaurant and so on since
this is so low priority it's it's going
to be very difficult for these two
people to go over to vegetarian they're
both kind of like oh I want to do what
you want to do you want to do steak
house right I want to eat together you
want to eat together let's do steak
house then and they they both don't
really know that they would be much
happier overall if they both hate
vegetarian and then this this would
really be even worse if if you had so
for example if you had like zero is here
then there's actually no way for them to
get there because there's no probability
there yeah whatever you because you're
initialization is to be very important
because if you initialize to the state
where they're both vegetarian then you'd
never want to leave and you'd be happy
to relieve it but if you neutralize to
blitz steak then you're in trouble so in
general in optimization in any kind of
optimization area where where you can
have this problem of falling into some
kind of local optimum that's worse than
the global optimum it's very dependent
on your initialization yeah because if
you're just over here then you'd fall
somewhere lower just by chance yeah yes
where you've initialized to a state
where it was zero would you have an
equal chance so the question was what if
you initialized into a state that had
zero probability so what you would do is
you would say is you would select a
variable you would select s1 and then
you would try out different values for
this you would say okay
I'm going to either choose s or V
holding x2 constant and in that case
transitioning to V would have a
probability of 1 so you would do that
almost deterministically so for Gibbs
sampling these are probabilities you
turn them into probabilities yeah yeah
so just to clarify get sampling is not
guaranteed to find the best assignment
it is not guaranteed yeah but we
mentioned something like in the limit it
is yes but that's so that's not like a
that's kind of a theoretical point it's
not really practical yeah it's so in the
limit doesn't mean like a guarantee I
guess yeah I guess you could interpret
it that way
yeah so I guess this is directly about
your question so if you were to compare
these questions which ones are
guaranteed to give you the maximum
weight assignment and the only one is
backtracking search because greedy is
too narrow beam search is maybe too
narrow
ICM is is too myopic and Gibbs sampling
is you it's not a guarantee it's likely
but it's not guarantee yeah
SR can you say or this example even in
the limit yeah so the question was in
this example even in the limit you
wouldn't converge and that's true so if
you if you initialized right here
there's no way for you to get over there
yeah so you yeah I think it's just in
certain conditions yeah
so that idea I wasn't my intent wasn't
to confuse you guys so if that's a it
was a theoretical point for like some
subsets some csps yeah yeah like you
said if we suppose initialized at stake
state it there's no point that we can go
to like vegetarians and stay in right
because in the middle transition
probabilities are 0 so is it like safe
to say that when you are modeling a
problem with give sampling you should
never like even if you encounter
property 0 just give them some epsilon
probability so that there might exist
some chance to yeah so the question was
is it worthwhile to add some like plus
point zero zero zero one to these just
to give it some probability and I my
intuition says that's it sounds like a
pretty good idea it sounds kind of like
adding tiny little Epsilon to avoid
division by zero but I think it would
depend on the problem that you're
solving well you can imagine some cases
where you would really want those zeros
okay so just to summarize so far we've
learned two ways of extending partial
assignments in these graphs so one is
backtracking search which we learned
last time which is like a full search of
that tree gives you the exact solution
every time super slow beam search is
approximate and it gives you this cool
little knob to trade-off speed and I
guess you could say like success or
exactness and then second we learn ways
to give in a assignment to improve it to
modify it
one was ICM which was approximate and
then the other is get something which is
also approximate but it uses some
probability some randomization
and now we're gonna look at is we're
gonna look at two ways to solve these
kinds of problems by actually changing
the structure of the graph itself so our
motivation comes from Australia Tasmania
that is that is the motivation
so Tasmania if you remember was
completely disconnected right so I think
we colored it red in the previous
example but it doesn't really matter
what color we gave to it right we give
it anything we wanted and so what we
want is we want to kind of leverage this
property and more than leverage it we
want to we want to kind of like inject
this property into graphs that don't
exhibit it we want to like build this
probability and this property out of
graphs so first we want like what is
this it's called independence and it can
speed things up so just like I said
before so is it still there my old
oh it's partially erased so if we write
this down again so this is the same
examples before we have two variables
each with a unary factor on it with
backtracking search I told you what
happened right you do something really
dumb which is you do it's it's like two
for loops right you try out every
combination of them which is exponential
where's what you could really do is just
say okay for each thing I'm gonna choose
the value that maximizes that makes my
factor most happy and that's linear time
and so that would give us a more
efficient algorithm no no
okay and we call that property
independence so a so in this case X 1
and X 2 are independent and the reason
that they're independent is their
there's no factor connecting them
there's no paths between them and
there's no edges between them and so we
call that independence and that's the
same thing with Tasmania in the rest of
Australia so I don't know how
independent it is like culturally
politically but it certainly is in terms
of like math coloring graph theory miss
and in simplest so we use this we use
this kind of cool-looking pipe thing and
that denotes independence so yeah so
like we said tasmania's independent what
about cases like this so it's not quite
independent but it's almost independent
you know only if X 1 didn't exist then
the rest none would be independent and
so that this is where we introduced this
idea of conditioning and conditioning is
a way to rip nodes out of a graph so and
we do that by by saying okay in in this
example let me draw it up so there's X 1
and X 2 and then it's 1 7 3 2 1 7 3 2 so
1 7 3 2 red red red blue blue 2
three seven one okay so we're saying X 1
and X 2 are connected to each other with
a factor right but what if I say X 2 is
definitely blue yeah yeah so the
question was can constraint satisfaction
problems be written as graphs and as all
of them yes yeah because fat because
variables are nodes and factors are
edges yes so it's actually a really
elegant way to think about it because
then you can bring in all this graph
theory stuff can you also see the board
okay I'll try to write big but okay so
if I say X 2 is definitely blue like
trust me it's blue then what's that let
me do it lets me cross out all the rows
where X 2 is not blue so here X 2 is red
so I can be like you are never gonna
happen I know you are not the case you
are not true and for you same thing you
are not happen and now once I fixed X 2
I don't all of X 2's values are the same
so this doesn't really add information
to this table and I can just drop that
data from the table and what that gives
me is it gives me a reduced table which
is just a unity factor of X 1 and it can
take on red or blue and then I have a
value of 7 if I choose red and 2 if I
choose blue and graphically what that
looks like is I'm deleting X 2 and I
just have one factor now X 1 and it has
a unary factor now the price to pay for
that was I had to assume that X 2 was
blue I had to conditioned on X 2 being
blue so
notationally or maybe like
programmatically well I think a good way
to think about it is it's kind of like
you're taking this the factor that
touches x2 and you're kind of like pre
loading it with a value for one of the
arguments and then the rest of is
untouched so you choose a value for a
variable you remove the value and the
variable from the graph and then you you
stick in that value you preload the
associated factors with that value so
for exhibit an example if we were to
condition on these then I'm saying si is
green and Q is blue eyes red trust me
and then what that does is it rips those
out of the graph and everything touching
everything touching those conditioned
variables turns into some kind of a
stump and you preload the value for
those variables in the only edge that
gets removed here is the one that
connects Si and Q and that's because you
have a function that takes two arguments
but you've pre-loaded both of those
arguments already so the it's done
there's nothing to do there might as
well not exist I'm just an example of
the new factors that go in so NT for
example that would this factor which
used to say NT and Q can't have the same
color it it turns into this little thing
which just says NT can't be red and you
know that because you are assuming that
Q you're conditioning on the fact that Q
is red yeah yeah so the question was is
independence no edge is independence
mean is there no edge between them or is
there no path between them and we will
talk about that so for independence you
would need both true but then we're
gonna cover an another form of
independence called conditional
independence which is just a ladder yeah
sending a partial assignment because I
actually like starting with a partial
assignment on the graph and they kind of
exploring or optimizing the rest of the
notes based on a partial assignment yeah
so the question was how is this
different from extending partial
diamonds and it's not so that's actually
a good point I think so conditioning
might actually be a case of building up
partial assignments this so what I think
the main thing to think about is now
we've kind of like moved on so partials
I'm extending partial assignments and
modifying existing partial assignments
that was kind of like our old world
which is where like this graph structure
is very perfect and we can't touch it or
change it now we're in a new world where
we're allowed to change the structure of
the graph and so we've kind of like left
that way of thinking yeah yeah so like
setting interior signature in what
drives the decision process of choosing
these values we will get into that yeah
yeah yeah so the question was why did we
choose to condition these so in this
example it's arbitrary but soon we're
gonna cover ways of choosing them what
how is this different from for checking
so in Ford checking what we were doing
is is we were propagating the decision
forward to reduce the domain of existing
factors whereas in this one we are we're
changing the structure of the graph
itself and we're we're literally
removing variables and inserting new
factors
okay so to move on graphically in
general what this looks like is if you
have a variable that you want to
condition you rip it out of the graph
and then everything that touches it
turns into some kind of a stub with the
value pre-loaded in there this is just a
picture of the same idea yeah so I guess
you could say this is the mean this is
the big difference is that whereas in
for propagation we were keeping the
existing graph and we're just
propagating our decisions to reduce
domains
whereas now we're we're literally
removing this variable and the factors
with it and then we're adding new
factors that are pre-loaded okay so we
are going to now go to what you were
asking about which is conditional
dependence so if you have three if you
have three variables a V and C so that's
like we have a C and B then you would
say that a and B are conditionally
independent because once you condition
on C once you pick a value for C
remember these turn into stubs or stumps
or whatever you want to call them geez
and so these are now independent they
used to not be independent because
there's there's a they could access each
other through C but now they're
independent there is no edge connecting
them and there's no way to reach each
other and so this this is just a way of
formalizing that this is how we write it
so we conditioned on C and then a and B
become independent
yeah so equivalent you say every path
from A to B goes through C and then that
means if you remove C then there's no
path connecting them so in this example
you have s a and Q if you condition on
them then you rip them out of the graph
and then it looks like western and
eastern Australia are now independent of
each other because the they've turned
into islands and that's writing it
mathematically
so there's another notion of the Markov
blanket which is basically saying okay I
went to make I've chosen some subset of
the graph in this case it's V and I want
to make it independent what is what what
are the variables I have to destroy in
order to make my variable in island so
in this case it would be essay in NSW if
you condition on these then V becomes an
island and it's independent if you
wanted to make this subset independent
then you and condition on Q and si and
this set of nodes and that you have to
condition on is called the Markov
blanket of the set of nodes that you
want to be independent so it's like if
you have some part of the graph a and
you want to make it independent of A
Part B then C is kind of like the Markov
blanket of a if when you delete it it
becomes independent of C this thing this
is kind of like a set notation thing
it's a set difference and this is just a
way of writing it more mathematically
so we can use these ideas to to like
create independent structures now of our
data so we had this example before where
it was almost independent but not quite
now what we can do is we can condition
on it so we condition this to be read
and then we can find the maximum weight
assignment of the rest of it which we
showed was easy before right with with
this example it's just linear like
what's the best for you what's the best
for you so once we condition on this
thing that's making it non independent
then it beat the poem becomes very easy
so what we do to solve this is we just
condition repeatedly we say okay I have
picked my node now for red green and
blue solve it condition and solve
condition and solve condition and solve
and this becomes very quick and then you
can read off the maximum weight very
easy you just say oh it's green because
that was the maximum weight I found once
after conditioning yeah so the product
so when it way the question was want to
talk about weights what does that mean
and this is it's kind of loosey-goosey
it's not very formally defined but in
this example I would say it's the weight
of the whole graph so your condition on
this and then you find the best values
for all of these variables and then you
take the products of all of those unary
factors and that gives you the weight
this is just an example yeah the numbers
are arbitrary yeah yeah our GM D doesn't
act the same as doing like all possible
combinations anyways like computation
right yeah it is so so it is so you
cover every solution that backtracking
would give you this would give you -
this is much faster because what you're
doing is you're taking a very
complicated problem and you're breaking
it into easily solvable pieces you're
taking an exponential problem and you're
breaking it into a linear number of
linearly solvable pieces and in practice
it's much faster yes yeah so the
question was instead of doing instead of
exhaust Li searching all variables
you're exhausted searching just a couple
variables and yeah that's an interesting
way of thinking about it I think in both
in both ways if you think about it
you're it's like even if you're
conditioning for every single variable
you're eventually going to consider all
of the values it can take on but you're
you're you're reordering things in a way
that's much smarter and that lets you
take care of like take advantage of this
independent structure in order to do it
better yeah
any more questions on this
yeah so it so it is faster than
backtracking and you could see it here
so for example if we did backtracking
here it would be what there's three
colors and there's seven nodes so it
would be this huge exponential blow-up
whereas if we condition here then it
becomes much smaller okay so just to
summarize independence is when we have a
and B and they can't there's no way to
get from A to B conditioning is when we
we take a vow we take a variable plug in
its value rip it out of the graph and
then like preload all the factors that
touched it yeah okay well I'll finish
this first a tional dependence is when
you have two blocks in your graph and if
you condition on one part of your graph
then if you rip that out then these two
become separated and then a Markov
blanket is saying okay I want to make my
variable an island what nodes do I have
to destroy it to make it an island yeah
whoa is your question
I guess I'm like unsure why it's
computationally cheaper because you try
a few condition on X one for each of the
colors you see I have to like like
you're basically you sought to come up
with three sets of unary factors for
each of the below variables you have to
write over each of their domains yeah it
also seems exponential so so in this
case so doing backtracking so if we did
backtracking so if we did backtracking
that would be what 7 to the third right
is that true 3 to 7 yeah and then if we
did conditioning so there'll be 3 for
the first condition right and then every
time we condition we do 7 times 3 right
6 times 6 times 3 yeah you're right 6
times 3 so this is is 6 squared right
what
thanks to six times it depends I don't I
don't I don't know exactly what these
factors are saying this is kind of an
arbitrary example but I think I think
the point the point here is that this is
smaller right so this is this is three
to the fourth or whatever so it's faster
yeah yeah down here yeah yeah so this
was saying this is saying that there's
three colors for x1 and then every time
I choose a color for x1 I'm saying that
there's three options for each of the
six other things so once I once I've
once I've set x1 it turns into this
situation where now I'm saying what's
the best value for x1 okay so I look at
three things and choose the best now
what's the best value for x2 and I look
at three things and choose the best and
so there's now there's six of these and
each one for each item I have to
consider three different possibilities
yeah I don't it you know it would
probably be different depending on what
these what the actual factors are and
what they're calculating but it's just
an arbitrary example okay so now we're
gonna do elimination elimination is very
cool I think so commissioning is saying
I'm gonna rip I'm gonna rip my variable
out of the graph and then I'm going to
plug in whatever value I conditioned on
into all the neighboring factors well
elimination says is is okay I'm gonna
rip my variable on the graph but instead
of instead of plugging in a single value
across every single factor I'm going to
plug in a different value per factor in
order to individually optimize each
decision so I think I think it's best
showing through example so again this is
the thing we have two variables and
they're connected by a factor and they
have
these weights if we condition then we I
think this is this example right so if
we condition we get what we got before
and then if we eliminate here I'll do
the elimination now so I'm going to
redraw this table so we have X 1 and X 2
we've red red red blue blue red and blue
blue
they have weights of 1 7 3 & 2 okay so
what elimination is going to do is is we
we condition it like internally
optimizes the value that we don't want
to condition on based on the other
arguments in that factor so we would say
okay we're trying we're trying to
eliminate X 2 right now and we do that
by looking at each value X 1 could take
on and then for each value we
dynamically choose the best value for X
2 so first we look at red so X 1 is red
what's the best value for X 2 in this
case it would be blue so we cross out
this row we say if X 1 is blue then X 2
is going to be red because that gives us
the biggest and then it just like before
now for for any value of x 1 the value
of x 2 is already set it's fixed it's
decided and so that means that we can
drop this variable out of the graph
because we've already like internally
optimized into this function what its
value would be and so this gives us
again a new table where we have X 1 we
have the values it can take on red and
blue and then we have the weights
associated with that which is now 7 and
so in math what that looks like is is
where we used to have this binary factor
we've now ripped x2 out of the graph and
we we have this new factor there's a
unary factor now which internally
optimizes over x2 it says give me my x1
give me an x1 and then as soon as you
get my x1 I'm going to spin through all
my values of x2 and give you the best
one that would the best match for it so
what this would look like in pictorially
I guess is every time you remove of
a factor you take all the factors that
touch it and you wrote them all together
and you merge them and into one big
factor and then internally what the
factor is doing is its optimizing over
whatever variable you just removed so
for example if we have so for example we
have this kind of coloring problem let's
say we want x1 to be red and x4 to be
red what's the best value of x3 that we
could give so over here we say x1 is red
x3 is red that gives us Volvo four and
then three to four red red gives us
value 1 so we have a 1 in here the other
value that x3 could take on would be
blue so now we go from red to blue which
gives us a value of 1 and then blue to
red which gives us a weight of 2 and so
we multiply those together we 1 times 2
which is 2 and then internally what this
factor is going to do is it's going to
maximize over those and choose the value
for the deleted variable that maximizes
that internally optimizes it for this
local problem which in this case is red
so just another example if we did red
blue so x1 is red x4 is blue there's two
options for x3 first it would be red so
if we go from red to red that's four and
then from red to blue is to say about
four times two here and then the next
thing would be if x3 is blue so we go
from red to blue which is one and then
blue to blue which is 1 and that's 1
times 1 and then we would say oh well in
this case the best value of x3 would be
red so it's kind of like internally
optimizing in general what this looks
like is you rip the node out of the
graph you take all the factors that used
to touch it and you tie them all
together into one big factor and again
that's kind of the mathematical notation
there's another way of interpreting this
that might be helpful to some people
basically it's like you it's like I pick
my value and then I'm going to look at
all the all the variables in its Markov
blanket and I'm going to repeatedly
condition for every on every assignment
that blanket can take on and then for
each of those conditionings what's the
best value of my selected variable
that's kind of what's going on behind
the scenes yeah
it's to like faster execution times well
just rip out all there was except for
one and then it becomes a unary factor
in a unary
yeah so the question was if if it's
faster to rip out variables why don't we
just do it for the whole graph and we
totally will
yeah you'll see it's in a couple slides
that's the algorithm so like we have
this strategy for ripping out variables
and then the next up is to use it to
solve the CSB which is what we're about
to do yeah okay
so there's this question which i think
is cool so if we have some kind of a
star shaped graph so if we have a setup
let's say we have a setup like this
which which is a bunch of factors going
into our hub and we have we have this
variable we'll call it s do we want to
run elimination or conditioning on s I
hear some whispers but oh yeah yeah
conditioning and the reason for that is
that if we if we condition then all
these turn into unary factors and if we
eliminate then it turns into one giant
factor which which is harder to solve
okay so like you were saying this is
this is the algorithm that you get out
of it so basically what you do is you
you loop through all your variables and
you eliminate them all in turn and then
at the end of the day you're going to
have one variable to rule them all and
that variable will just hold the best
answer yeah to a case where if we don't
have a yeah yeah so the question was
wait a second doesn't ordering still
matter like can't we still end up
somewhere that's not good and that's
totally true so towards the end of this
lecture is a discussion on exactly that
topic variable ordering does matter and
it's actually hard it's an np-complete
problem is to decide the best variable
ordering but so I think I'm gonna do one
more example of I'm gonna run
elimination on a whole graph which I
think will be helpful so
our graph so we have three variables we
have X we have Y and we have Z and
they're all connected through a single
factor I'm going to write out the whole
table for this so we have X we have Y
and we have Z and let's say they have
two values they could be a or b so we
have a a a a a B I'm gonna run out of
space a B be a B a B a a b a b b b a and
b b b is everything one two three four
five six seven eight yeah okay so
hopefully this is readable but and they
help weights right so we can just
arbitrarily say there one two three four
five six seven eight
can people make this out
seems like maybe so I will go with it
okay so what do we do let's say we want
to choose Z first we want to eliminate Z
so will we do an elimination is we say
for all the variables in Z's Markov
blanket we're going to repeatedly
condition on the values that they can
take on and then we're going to
dynamically choose the value of Z that
would best match that so x and y could
either be a and a so this is a a and in
this case the best value of Z would be B
right so we cross this out next x and y
could be a B in which case the best
value Z is a let's we cross this out it
could be be a which would be B or it
could be be B and the best value of Z in
this case would again be B so again like
we've seen a couple of times before now
for any value of x and y the value of Z
is already decided it's set it's pre
computed so we can just drop this
variable from our table which is
equivalent to dropping it from our graph
ok so now we're gonna work on Y again we
do the same thing we say for each for
each value in Y is Markov blanket which
is X we repeatedly condition on all the
possible values it could take on and
then dynamically choose the best of that
value based on that so if X is a so now
we're comparing so now we're comparing
these two so if X is a what's the best
value of y its B so we can cross this
out now if X is B what's the best value
of y it's again B so we can cross this
out and now again for every value of x
we've decided B and so we can drop this
from the graph
and now what we have is now we have one
variable in our graph with a unary
factor so we have X and X can be a or it
can be B and if X is a and then it has a
value of 4 and if X is B then it has a
value of 8 and now what we can do is we
can just say okay we're going to choose
X to be 8 and then in kind of
implementation all you need to do is is
kind of like look back you could store
some kind of back pointers or store your
own tables and you can recover your
solution from the whole graph from this
endpoint
so that is that is variable elimination
yeah why do we go in the opposite order
from engine one instead of lunch at them
oh that's so that that's basically that
was what I that was um that kind of is a
mathematical way of saying what I just
said about the back pointers so it's
like now we've gone forward and we've
eliminated and now we can go backward to
say okay X is B now that we've decided X
to be be like we look at our old table
and be like what was the best value of y
that gave us that decision so it's kind
of like once you go forward to eliminate
you get your solution and then you go
back and like read off the values as you
go yeah okay
so in terms of runtime basically what
you could say is so for each variable
it's going to have domain to the so
every variable is going to have domain
to the era T the factory touching so the
factors touching like the factor you
create from eliminating a variable is
going to have this many rows in it and
then there's n variables that you have
to eliminate and with that why the
reason why it's max arity is because if
you have let's say you had some kind of
graph that looks like this the this
factor would be d squared the Des Moines
squared and then this factor would be d3
and so like eyes are going as you're
eliminating going through this graph
like this is just gonna dominate d2 so
its eyes you're going through one
alumina graph the arity of the biggest
factor you've created is going to bound
you
four minutes and that's where variable
reading gets in so what was it yeah yeah
so the first one I'm not actually sure I
thought about I looked I looked around
and I I wasn't able to explain it so
yeah okay so but as you're going order
matters because if you looked at this
there's two ways to do it right so if
you went from the leaves and eliminated
each leaf variable first then all the
factors you create would have era t1
it'd be super easy but if you eliminated
x1 first then you get this huge giant
factor that gives you this big table of
this era t6 would you be ever so so the
order really matters in general it makes
sense to eliminate variables with the
fewest neighbors first it's a pretty
like sensible heuristic that in practice
works well and we define this term
called true width which is saying if you
had a factor graph and you're going
through doing elimination the back so
emeriti of a factor that you create
along the way using the best ordering is
the truth of that glass so in general a
truth is is very very hard to compute
but for a few cases you can kind of
Reason about it so for example if you
had a chain let's say we had a chain and
if I was going through eliminating this
the biggest factor out create is just a
unary just that little guy right so true
worth of one if I had a tree so it's
just like our example before so if you
go from the leaves again you can create
these little factors these little unary
factors and so you can get away with one
if you had a cycle
I'll make my psyche a little bigger but
if you had a cycle the max emeriti is
gonna be too because even if even if you
kind of work away from the sides you're
eventually going to end up as something
that just connects the last things
before you delete them so it's like you
have your cycle and you chew way at both
ends and you're gonna end up with
something with just those two nodes
relating remaining and then if you had a
n by n grid if you have an N by n grid
so let's say this just goes on it's the
smaller of the two and the reason for
that is because if you let's say you go
through and you're eliminating these
things to like that and like that you're
gonna end up with something some
situation like this and once you delete
this you're gonna get a factor that
ropes them all together yeah so that's
true with super important hard to
compute yeah
oh yeah yeah oh yeah you're right so
it's not the first - it's the it's not
the last - it's the first - so when
you're let's say this is my cycle
the first factor I create after I delete
that is gonna be a binary factor yeah so
thank you for that
yeah so just to summarize we learned
different ways of solving csps add a
beam search which is kind of like a
souped up version of backtracking
which doesn't always give you the answer
but it's faster local search you get
entire things and then you improve them
a little bit at a time
conditioning break up the graph into
smaller pieces that are easier to solve
unknown elimination which is where it's
kind of like in conditioning except
instead of choosing one value for all
your factors you kind of like
dynamically choose the value based on
the Markov blanket and that's CSPs so we
will see you on Wednesday